I'm delighted to see you all and I'm
actually thrilled the digital
preservation would
it's very promising I must say that I'm
quite honored to be here in this lecture
series because following the two
previous Jim Marley and Helen Shenton
who have made such significant
contributions to the profession I want
to just make clear that I I don't see
myself in that same role rather as
someone who sort of walks the border
between people who use preserved
information and people who actually
preserve the information so I'm
delighted to be here in that capacity I
will not speak about preservation today
from a professional perspective because
I am after all a historian not a
preservationist as Bobby said nor will I
speak necessarily from a personal point
of view although I want to make clear
that all the views of express are
actually strictly my own and not those
of any organization with which I worked
I also want to say that I'm going to
speak in a very strong voice I'm not
going to be very nuanced about what I
say so I imagine that this will spark a
number of questions but I want to just
sweep away some of the cobwebs in terms
of general understandings of
preservation and of the specific role
the digital preservation plays in our
culture today because that's what I want
to talk about I want to talk about
preservation from a social perspective
the role of preservation in culture and
particularly our culture at this moment
which are characterized as the age of
abundance of information it's a period
of information profligacy and I think
actual promiscuity but it also it
doesn't mean that we have any more
attention span in fact the challenges
that we have more information and the
same finite amount of attention and I
think this goes very much to the thing
that I want to talk about most and that
is the need to shape and select the
historical record in a way that we have
not done in an analog preservation not
that we haven't done it but we've done
it in a very different way so I want to
focus on the social context of digital
preservation preservation of born
digital materials most of all I want to
talk about the value the value of
preservation for society and so I will
actually talk about the economics
information I don't want you to be
worried I'm not an economist either and
I'm not going to talk economies but I
have worked with economists on this
issue and they have a lot to tell us
about value and how societies decide to
commit resources to one thing and not to
another what I say will apply in part to
analog materials that have been
converted to digital but I really want
to address the challenge of born digital
because it is the particular challenge
that has been given to us in this
generation whether we like it or not and
whether we trained for this this is
actually our challenge now and it's
something that we need to take very
seriously because the clock is ticking
on a whole variety of fronts and it's
not just the content that we need to be
preserving its the professional skills
that we need to develop in order to deal
with a very changing environment of
information and changing value of
information and by economics I'm not
going to talk about cost models or
business models or anything having to do
with capitalism or the free market I
mean simply that the allocation of
resources which are always scarce to
some things and not to another so how is
it that we decide to put money here
because it's always at the expense of
something else or so we think and so how
do we actually make those decisions it's
about judgments and it's about it's
about our sense of value because
everything that has a value costs
something people time and yes money so
where does preservation fit into the
list of things that our society deems
most important if not essential in other
words as I sometimes wonder does anybody
out there really get it how important
preservation is and the answer that
question is yes definitely they
definitely do people definitely get the
value of preservation and society they
have a special name for it they call it
access I think the problem from the
reservations point of view is that what
they don't get is that there's a
relationship between preservation and
access that without preservation there
can be no access and i think that
there's a way that we in the
preservation community and people who
care about the historical record can if
not make them care about preservation
for the process itself can make them
care very much about the outcomes of
preservation and therefore support
preservation as it should be I mean this
is as this lack of identification
between access and preservation is acute
in the digital realm partly because
digital content is so is not very
long-lived and I mean that many sense
there hasn't been information or digital
information for long and it certainly
doesn't last that long but the failure I
think goes far deeper than this sort of
you know what me worry storage is cheap
you know Alfred E Newman's school of of
preservation which I've heard an
astounding number of technologists say
technologists who really should know
better because they've lost data so I
just I I want to say just a word about
the idea of cheap storage and this is a
very serious point storage requires
energy and we're not just talking about
digital storage we're talking about all
forms of storage as you know the use of
power will never ever be cheap I
remember the days i miss the days
actually when experts would say that you
know energy is actually not going to be
a problem because of nuclear power then
in fact nuclear power will be so cheap
that we will stop metering it and I
think that we are now living through an
absolutely horrifying catastrophe that
shows just how expensive not only energy
is a nuclear power in particular but how
incredibly dependent we are on the power
grid in ways that we can hardly
calculate I'm not saying that you know
we should go back to paper but I am
saying that we need to attend to the
entire spectrum of issues that that are
related to digital storage and the
digital life cycle it goes far beyond
server it goes beyond the power grid
itself so the message about preservation
needs to be heard at the very highest
levels it needs to be seen as critical
infrastructure which of course it is I
think more to the point the it's cheap
so we can store everything mrs. the
single most important point which is not
everything is equally valuable it avoids
the very tough question of selection
which i think is absolutely critical and
even more so in an age of abundance and
I know this is very controversial
some areas and even in Special
Collections where people feel that
selection is a way of limiting and
biasing the historical record that it's
difficult and it is by definition
prejudicial and I say yes it is but we
have no choice in fact selection and
collection building has always been
culturally inflected it has always
reflected the cultural biases of the
people who create information and the
people who are successive stewards of
that and I have to say as a historian
you know I got that I understood that
the historical record was not absolutely
reflective of everything that's why I
went to school to learn how to use
resources and to have them tell me what
I wanted to hear rather than rather than
just rely on the things that were there
and furthermore it makes me believe that
no matter what we leave to some extent
the skill of interpretation lies with
the interpreter but we need to give them
the best possible perspective the best
possible choice i will say also that
having studied for a long time in the
USSR I don't believe that information
wants to be free I actually think the
historical record is extremely important
to be conscious stewards of because
information is very easy to use and to
manipulate for whatever purposes you
want good or ill and just one fun hoard
of introduction and those are my priors
before we start talking about the good
news about digital preservation as well
as some of the cautions and that is what
i know is both as an historian and
because of the people that I have worked
with I've spent many years working in
the library of congress and working with
the Library of Congress and in many
other places in which I've just sponged
up as much information as I could and I
think the thing that I learned most
importantly was what I saw the
audiovisual preservationist grapple with
at the Library of Congress that audio
visual you're already dealing with an
historical record which is extremely
fragile which is already discounted
historically is not significant although
you know we find out too late that it is
significant and so and also how to deal
with things which are dynamic
is that our dynamic in time because I
think this is another challenge in
digital preservation is a mindset that
preservation is about fixing things once
and for all having the right standards
fixing the right version this is simply
not going to be the case in digital
preservation so I think for those who
are shy about getting into digital
preservation at least make friends with
friends and audio with with people in
audio-visual preservation because they
have a lot of this in their DNA how to
actually look at this kind of material
and assess its value so I want to start
with the good news about digital
preservation because there has been
enormous amount of good news and it is
mostly good news it's amazing to think
how far we've gotten in just 15 years
roughly first in terms of awareness the
fact is that there are a lot of people
who are aware of the need for digital
preservation now you could say that
everyone has experienced some loss of
data or having to upgrade data
understands that there is also there are
a huge number of technical advances and
I won't list them all because there are
so many but in terms of preservation
improved bit storage including the move
to the cloud which i think is going to
give us some kind of scale that we have
longed for also better understanding of
file formats and there has been enormous
amount of work done in preservation
metadata really spectacular work in
preservation metadata we are also seeing
on the landscape increased institutional
commitments to digital preservation and
I think of that from our perspective in
this library that's the most significant
we've seen national libraries taking
responsibility for some domain we see
movie studios seriously investing in
digital preservation financial companies
have been doing this for a long time and
there are a lot of data archives you
know it's not as if we have to invent
digital preservation for ourselves in
the library world most most everything
that we want to know and use has been
has been done already in forged for us
in another sector some institutions have
even sprung up just to deal with
preserving the cultural heritage I say
some but in fact I have in mind one
which is the Internet Archive the
internet archive that started
1996 with a typical sort of know no
bounds I want everything approach and
it's been simply doing and learning it's
an iterative approach that its founder
Brewster Kahle knows from the tech world
you got a problem you try a solution
that doesn't work you try it again you
never wait for version 3.0 because then
it's too late and I think that that's
very hard for some library staff to
understand library professionals to
understand coming from at least a
paper-based world I think also the other
thing that's important is on the issue
of scale we've seen several models of
shared stewardship emerge I think
everybody who knows the least bit about
digital technology knows that preserving
data can't be done in in the old
fashioned library way of you know one
library one campus and siloed
collections in fact there has to be a
scaled effort to build at least the
infrastructure for digital preservation
this has been forged by the National
Science Foundation when they put
together the office of cyber
infrastructure in which they felt that
all of their extremely well-funded
preservation sorry science directorates
still could not tackle preservation on
their own or the building of the
infrastructure it had to be done at
scale which meant across institutions
and disciplinary lines I want to touch
briefly on some bad news which is which
is essentially all of the above
everything that I said has some downside
to it not surprisingly so in the area of
technical advances we've made enormous
strides in preservation advances but we
have not kept pace with the technical
advances in the creation of information
in fact a work we're falling very far
behind there's not much we can do about
that but that is the case that the
ability to create data will always
outstrip our ability to preserve it and
we have already technically far exceeded
the amount of information there is has
far exceeded the storage capacity
worldwide and this is just a scientific
data so even those people who were power
users are beginning to understand that
they can't be
they can't save everything I want to say
about awareness I think there is a great
deal of awareness in the cultural
heritage institutions about the need for
digital preservation but we see a lot of
institutions saying but that doesn't
mean me that doesn't mean me because I
don't have the capacity I don't have the
funding I don't have the expertise and
the I think the the saddest case is in
my mind are historical societies and
smaller regional libraries and then the
major metropolitan public libraries
which have a very valuable role in
collecting regional history not just
serving the public best sellers and I
think that they're really bereft they're
really left on their own in this world
and so that's why I think the idea of
shared stewardship is even more
important to build a robust
infrastructure that small institutions
can use almost as a kind of service
bureau and I think the preservation
world has really modeled this extremely
well in in the field services that they
provide in some of the some of the
service bureaus that they have for
preservation that serve very small
constituents after all we know that that
local history and the micro is very
important now I want to speak slightly
against grain here and talk about the
bad news in terms of institutional
commitments because I talked about
national libraries financial companies
movie studios I want to know where the
ARL libraries are in this and i'm not
talking about converted materials when
they've done a spectacular job of
converting their materials for access
purposes nor am i talking about the
extensive work that has been done in
negotiating access to scholarly
literature which is born digital access
which has a preservation back end in
many cases there's a kind of if you go
out of business we get to keep this I'm
talking about the born digital material
that the humanists of the future will be
using not scholarly literature but the
primary sources of our culture I think
to a surprising degree I think research
libraries whose specialty actually is
that have been really missing in action
and i think that there's a significant
risk that that this will go on for some
time if libraries
just step in and try to do it and do
just a little bit you don't have to do
much but work with your special
collections area you know what the
you're collecting strengths are just go
out and do some web archiving or or
something else partner with people who
are digital creators because there's a
lot of opportunity there for your feet
to get wet in a kind of no-fault area I
think that from an economic point of
view there might be very compelling
reasons why research libraries are among
the last to enter into the space that
not among the last but but certainly
laggards I'd say considering the
importance of these institutions and it
is as I learned from economist on the
Blue Ribbon task force it's an economic
reason it's because to some extent
libraries have lost their incentive to
preserve and I know that sounds
counterintuitive because why would a
library need an incentive if in fact
it's their mission to preserve but I
think that that sometimes missions are
lip service and that you can have a
mission that you're not able to fulfill
and it still means a great deal to you
but it's not something which is
actionable that you will actually
dedicate a lot of money to and I think
preservation is at risk of becoming this
in the digital world I think the
incentive for libraries to preserve
analog collections has been access you
could not serve readers without
providing a book for them and you could
not serve this faculty without having
books that data from 1850 or before it
was simply something that you had to do
libraries weren't founded around
preservation they were founded around
access and preservation was built as a
back-end to support access that people
wanted you know the the country has been
very slow at a policy level to move in
step with the digital realm the
copyright law despite recommendations
for tiny incremental changes to section
108 to allow copying of digital
materials for libraries that law has not
the law has not been amended our
Congress seems to be quite distracted by
a number of other things I'd say in the
meantime the good news is in the
meantime copyright law has has become
quite irrelevant to
large number of people who are creating
data and I think that that that gives us
a real opportunity I don't think that as
long as materials are licensed and we
deal with the licensing regime as
opposed to the copyright law we're going
to be doing significantly differently
than we are now and I think we've made
considerable strides in that area but
there's a lot of even in the area of
scholarly literature there's an
increasing amount of scholarship which
is written outside of journals which is
very important there are lots of
scholarly blogs in certain fields were
actually which are quite preservation
worthy and are looking for homes for
preservation I want to talk also about
the the good news of shared stewardship
models because in fact I mean I talked
about the the the shared stewardship
model as a good thing and it is actually
there have been large number on the SE n
dip is worn program and locks is another
and haughty trust is yet a third but
particularly when it comes to
universities there's a downside to that
which is sharing is not easy and the
universities are particularly the ones
that have the richest collections there
in a very competitive stance one with
another they compete for students they
compete for faculty they compete for
collections they competed sports and I
think that this is very much out of step
with what's needed in the digital world
I do believe that in fact there are
universities talking about building
shared preservation infrastructure
because they've encountered already that
this is not something they can do except
collectively i would say locks is an
example of that haathi Trustin is an
example of that but i think it's a very
serious issue which needs to be
addressed in the next couple of years
and I expect Yale will be part of the
solution for that and be eager to join I
mean even Harvard has announced that
it's willing to join in some aspects of
sharing collections and preservation so
I would say there's a fairly good
example up in the brick campus up north
I want to spend the rest of my time here
talking specifically about some of the
findings from the
Blue Ribbon task force unsustainable
digital preservation and access it's in
part because I think this is work that
tends to be that that hasn't gotten a
lot of traction because it looks like
it's about economics and I think that
that scares a lot of people away but I
think it's actually a salubrious way of
looking at the challenges of building
support for preservation because in the
end preservation has to pay its away it
doesn't have to pay its way financially
but it has to be something that society
says it is willing to invest in as
opposed to something else and I think we
can make a very good case for that
several years ago the National Science
Foundation and the Library of Congress
got together to put thinking it wanted
to get preservationist sand economists
you know academic economists real
economists to talk about the fundamental
economics of digital sustainability why
because digital preservation had been
dealt with as a technical problem and as
a legal problem and is a collecting
problem but never seriously as an
economic problem and I'll say economists
do not think of what they do is business
business models and cost models that's
actually what people in business school
do as they as they told me on the task
force they actually look at societies
engagement with the commitment of
resources to things that they care about
so we looked at it from a very global
perspective we had we worked for two
years and we've produced to reports the
first report was purely descriptive it
just looked at the world and said what
have we done what solutions are there
for digital preservation and paying for
it and what lessons have been learned
what are the things that people have
tried that have not succeeded that we
should not try the second year was what
we call normative looking at where we're
going or actually in this case looking
at where we wanted to go and then
plotting a course for how we got how we
would get there from here it did
sometimes feel like that him that you
know like we were in Maine and the
person went to say well we can't get
there from here you know but in fact
there is there is a way to engage all
the sectors that we need in
economic support of this activity in
some ways simply by recalibrating how we
describe what we do and addressing a
different audience than we have um the
The Economist did a very good job of
characterizing preservation as an
economic activity and I won't i won't
give you their economies it's incredibly
funny and amusing to hear them describe
preservation in economic terms they have
an array of technical terms which are
really quite interesting and get at some
very core concepts but as the writer of
the report I found that they needed
translation constantly and so I will
speak to you in translated economies and
tell you that for digital preservation
we determined that there were five
conditions for sustainability and and
they're only five conditions this is all
incidentally in the report and I will
tell you how to find the report at the
end of the of the talk I'm not going to
give you a URL i will give you the title
again so you can google it the URL is a
little ungainly so the five conditions
for support are a recognition of the
benefits of preservation by decision
makers and a decision makers anybody
who's in a position to commit a resource
to something or to influence a decision
i should say who is a decision maker at
yale well obviously the president is the
head of the library is anybody who runs
a budget is but the faculty are also
decision makers they can set priorities
for what's important on campus so but
the important thing is to recognize the
benefits of preservation that is it that
is what is it that stakeholders get out
of preservation again it's about the
outcomes the second thing that's needed
is a process for selecting digital
materials with long-term value that's
very very difficult and I think people
found at the most difficult task but
there was absolutely no interest in
anybody from the task force coming out
and saying that we should be keeping
everything because we can it was very
clear to the people who put this who
charged the task force that in fact
presidents of universities for example
would not
invest in digital preservation if they
thought it was a black hole and it would
be collecting everything
indiscriminately they wanted a lot of
work going into a selection which i
think is very smart there have to be
incentives the third is there have to be
incentives for decision-makers to make
the decision to preserve in the public
interest and I will talk a little bit
about incentives because it seems like a
sort of odd thing to talk about in
preservation and odd in terms of mission
work but in fact incentives are key to
actually getting things done there needs
to be the fourth is there need to be
needs to be appropriate organization and
governance of digital preservation
activities and I'll say that I'd be
surprised if this campus were any
different than any campus I've ever been
on where digital preservation happens in
multiple places and nobody knows where
they are nobody knows what other people
are doing and they don't even know about
the duplication of effort that they're
making so it is really critical that
there be a strategy for digital
preservation and that people know what
the strategy is and there be clear lines
of responsibility for for who does what
we heard from many government agencies
that produce public records that you
know or by law to be preserved when
somebody was ready to hand off a record
a digital record for example be he a
scientist in a laboratory or somebody in
immigration they returned to someone and
say was so where do I send this and
there was no answer nobody knew who was
in charge and so I think it's quite
essential that people beat asked
specifically and that second that
everybody knows who is tasked
specifically about who is in charge of
what it's the only way to actually
implement the strategy because it is
after all quite we're dealing with
ephemeral and distributed materials it's
not as if somebody can just put a whole
bunch of books in a room and say okay
let's take care of this it has to be
handled in a distributed way the fifth
challenge is the mechanisms for securing
ongoing and efficient allocation of
resources to digital preservation
activities efficient doesn't mean cheap
means that you get the biggest bang for
your buck so there's a there's an
appropriate amount of redundancy but
there's not unnecessary duplication not
surprisingly the things that people
found the greatest challenge about
meeting those conditions I shouldn't say
incidentally that the first year we
spent looking for somebody who could
claim that they had fulfilled all five
of those conditions and the closest we
got was somebody who thought they were
doing sort of three maybe four but then
on closer examination when we asked them
questions decided no they weren't
actually doing that many either so it's
complicated and it's not as if there's
there's a model out there that people
can hand off to somebody else getting
into conversation I think with people
other people who were doing digital
preservation is possibly the first
intelligent step but almost an order of
the challenges I'll tell you what they
were the first was uncertainty about
selection criteria which I mentioned for
assessing long-term value on the one
hand we had scientists talking about
large scale data sets some of them could
say well we know that those that you
know those petabytes of data from space
will not be useful after 10 years
because you know we'll have superseded
the observational data with something
else on the other hand there was a
different set of astronomers who said
you know what all has drawn all
astronomy astronomical data is
historical data we can't get rid of
anything so they were having a hard time
sorting through that one but they did
realize they had to make a choice so
they were thinking about ways to sample
historical data so that they could do it
cheaply we also found a great challenge
where the small handcrafted digital
collections many of which are bound on
campuses made by students and faculty
members and then the biggest one which
we decided we couldn't avoid is the
plethora of new genres that are emerging
on the wet web mediated by social media
and the so called open web things like
Wikipedia and Twitter things that we
know are of enormous social significance
but what part of it is significant how
we collected how we save it where the
copyright in
and ownership claims to it not a clue
absolutely not a clue I think it was on
the on the basis of the the complete
golf about how important it was versus
knowing what to do about it that really
prompted the library of congress to say
you know we're going to take the twitter
archive we don't know what that means we
have no idea what that means but Twitter
doesn't either and and who better to
find out with than twitter so i mean
that's the kind of partnership where you
can go into it with an expectation of
failure but it's a failure but the but
failures are learning experiences if its
failure without a learning experience
than it is really a failure but if you
go into something knowing that you'll
the outcome actually is knowledge not
necessarily saving something then you
can get pretty far with trying out
different methods for selection like I
tell tell you my colleagues at the
library that were absolutely gobsmacked
when the first public reaction besides
some people saying hey that's great
where people individually trying to
reach individuals in the library of
congress saying that twitter I want my
twitter back you know I didn't know that
it was going to be preserved forever I
never knew that it was you know then
anyone had a right to preserve it and
and of course it's all very clear on the
Twitter when you click through that
license that unless you make an
exemption you know it is actually it's
not your private property anymore and
and people publish this online and it's
totally accessible but they're very
sensitive about it being preserved so
you run into some very unexpected issues
simply by trying things out there's also
another challenge which I'll get into
it's quite specific in every community
the Scala community where a scientific
community or in Hollywood for example
but there's a really fundamental miss
misalignment of incentives to preserve
copyright law is completely out of whack
with what we need to be doing in terms
of copyrighted materials and the
the rewards in the Academy for attending
to digital preservation where it matters
the most are also out of whack and I
will actually spend some time with on
talking about that there and then
finally I want to say that the other
thing that was really baffling which I
don't think we're ever going to solve is
is trying to discriminate between
preservation the cost of making
something accessible versus the cost to
making something preserving something in
fact they're not separable and so
teasing out preservation costs as
opposed to access costs is a fool's game
I think it's much better to think of
long-term sustained data management in
which you look at every object as having
a life cycle and the life cycle can be
five years it can be one year and it can
be 50 years but it's much more useful to
think about life cycle costs and
lifecycle management of digital data and
it also makes it a whole lot easier to
think about selection in this in this
case the the really good news is we did
find that once the risks were identified
and we recommended everybody doing an
assessment and where they are with this
make us do a self assessment of where
they are based on some of the things in
our report we found that in fact for
nearly everything that we thought of as
a risk there is a mitigation there is
actually a lot to be done in order to
make the environment friendly for
digital preservation and the really good
news i think is that it is everybody's
problem it's not you know it's not yells
problem and it's not my problem it's
actually everybody's problem so when
rumor first spread that that the Library
of Congress and NSF we're looking to put
together this task force on economics we
had a flood of people volunteering time
and effort and money and a lot of
interest on the part of people in a
university administration of course they
also thought that we would hand them a
blueprint for what what is to be done
actually a business model as opposed to
an economic model but I think economic
models are business models are actually
pointless without our neck
model and we did get fairly far to
articulating several types of economic
models some for-profit and for the
for-profit sector and some
not-for-profit so the three things that
I want to say is the you know final
recommendations which I think are most
important for this community are and
they're they're just three and they're
not you know they're not easy is first
and foremost to articulate a compelling
value proposition for preservation I
said first that in the beginning that
people really do care about preservation
they just don't call it preservation
they call it access I think that
particularly in the preservation field
if you really want to get more resources
and the right kind of resources for work
start talking about the outcomes of
preservation start talking about the
things that you can do with preserved
assets or however you want to call them
in scientific world they can talk about
the promise of future productivity of
science how do we talk about that in the
library how do we actually talk about
the future productivity of our students
and our faculty well we talked about it
actually all the time that without the
collections research and teaching is
really engendered so talk first about
what the outcomes of preservation are
going to be and then talk about what it
takes to get there from here when the
value proposition of saving astronomical
data is going to be different from
saving feature films for example but
every audience has its own sort of sweet
spot in terms of what it really wants to
pay attention to but i think i would
start first with what are you what is
the benefit of preservation that's the
recognition of benefit on the part of
stakeholders the second thing is to is
to provide clear incentives to preserve
in the public interest what does that
mean to provide incentives unclear
incentives to preserve in the public
interest while providing incentives for
stakeholders as we say anybody who cares
about the outcome of preservation to
preserve digital assets directly or to
provide preservation services for others
and tailoring those incentives to the
prevailing community norms and to
information policy regulations and
privacy concerns is really what we're
talking about
we're talking about both creating
incentives positive things that get
people to preserve and also removing
disincentives of which there are many to
take a fairly simple example I'll take a
bench scientist at Yale University or
medical scientist at Yale one incentive
that a scientist has to to preserve
digital data is the possibility of
reusing the data if in fact they're
interested in sharing the data a much
stronger incentive would be if his grant
depended upon digital curation if the
grant actually stipulated that the data
had to be managed and archived and the
digital curation was part of the grant
and there was money in the grant for it
and there would be a penalty be paid if
curation didn't happen now that's really
an incentive it's one thing for NSF to
say everybody needs to save their data
and curate their data it's not but
that's not enough because I can't think
of as we actually asked people at the
foundation and they said well privately
they didn't know of any particular grant
which had been denied API because they
hadn't saved data from a previous grant
they give them a hard time maybe but
they didn't actually deny research funds
research funds is what researchers care
about so holding back money would be
very important a big advance is that NSF
is now saying that people have to have a
data management plan that's very good
nobody knows what a data management plan
is yet but I see this as an opportunity
for libraries frankly I mean how many of
you have gone over to to science
laboratories and say hey you've got a
data management plan you're worried
about maybe I can help you this is
really an opportunity to begin data
curation where it counts which is at the
bench I'd also say that there are
positive disincentives for scientists to
curate data and what are they well
because every every second every money
every penny that's not spent on research
it's really a demerit in his portfolio
because there is no reward in his reward
system or her reward system for curating
and preserving data it's just time away
from something that is rewarded so I
think the the incentives are really out
of
within the university itself that on the
one hand you reward people for creating
data on the other hand there's a
positive disincentive for people
preserving data and somehow they think
that all of some how things are going to
end up in the library sort of magically
packaged and ready for you to take care
of and serve up again this is a
fundamental misunderstanding data
curation really begins with the creator
and it should be in partnership with
librarians preservationist data
scientists informatics specialists
whatever you want to call them every
discipline will have a different name
but it's a partnership that begins at
the very beginning I think that that
libraries have well I should say
universities have a second opportunity
as well as a responsibility and that is
you have thousands of students coming
through here every year you teach them
literacy in many ways media literacy
reading literacy mathematical literacy
digital literacy is what is needed now
because our students are digital they've
grown up digital they know how to use
machines fluently many times a better
than we do we think we fear but that
doesn't mean that they're literate
necessarily and they know how to use
information well there's a chance that
and as well as an obligation that we can
take the current generation of sort of
web 2.0 Earth's sort of readwrite
culture of Technology and turn it into a
read/write curate and preserve culture I
think that everybody who goes through an
undergraduate program at any good
university college or actually it should
start in high school people should be
taught how to manage their own data
while they're creating it not just how
to create a paper or a project that gets
an A and it be judged only on the
intellectual merit but just as much as
you would give it a marriage for
plagiarism for example or worse than a
demerit not taking care of data properly
file naming formats and things like that
is something that people need to learn
essentially from the cradle because it's
not something that they're going to into
it until it's too late so finally let me
just end with a few
rotations to people particularly in the
library and particularly in preservation
I think that first I want to emphasize
again how crucial selection is I think
that archivists have a unique
perspective on dealing with abundance
and sorting through what's important to
document what's important to say what's
important to sample and I think
audio-visual archivists are particularly
adapted this I think we have a lot to
learn from them I also think that
preservation is I know this will sound
somewhat bold and even counterintuitive
in these budgetary times but I really do
believe passionately that preservation
is emerging as a keystone of the
University and its its social worth I
really think in this time when universe
universities feel besieged by so much
and their whole social mission is under
question from many sectors they can
claim rightly so that they contribute to
knowledge that they really contribute to
the knowledge economy but so do a lot of
other sectors a lot of private sectors
can contribute to knowledge as well the
one thing that the private sector will
never do and this was demonstrated
roundly by our economies they will never
care about preservation they will never
ensure the continuity of information
from one generation to another it is
impossible for market forces to actually
take care of that and so I think that of
all the things that libraries do on
University campuses I can I have heard
people on university's administration
speculating how all of them could go
away many of the things we love most
about libraries can very well be
imagined is being superseded by
commercial services frankly search for
example access for example but no one
believes that anybody but a university
is going to preserve and so I think it
means that this is really the Golden Age
of preservation that if the university
can really configure a lot of its
information culture around the creation
and curation of data that the library
really stands to benefit enormously it
means a lot of changes in the profession
of of preservation means working with a
lot of different skills and developing
different skill sets and we
have before but I really believe that it
is it really is the beginning of a
marvelous age for preservation
preservation the paradigm preservation
for the digital world is not about
fixity it's about incremental
responsibilities you can think long term
but really incrementally the key is to
think about handoffs secure handoffs
making sure that data is well curated
and making sure that it is handed off to
somebody who can curate it and stored it
in the next step I think you have a lot
of skills on campus that are very good
at this I think there are many people at
the by Nikki who know precisely how to
identify really important content
creators and collectors of content how
to develop relationships with them and
how to ensure that their collection of
information comes to the by Nikki when
they are ready to move it to a
stewardship organization take that
paradigm move it online go to digital
creators and I think you have exactly
the same thing going on you know what is
it that makes this obligation for
preservation so important I think it's
important for us not just as individuals
and as families and as researchers at
universities but I think it is really
vital for us as a species as Homo
sapiens and I mean that quite literally
we differ from our fellow species in
many ways but scientists are telling us
every day we differ a lot less from our
fellow species than we think but there's
one thing incontestably we differ from
all of the species with and that is the
ability to create artificial memory to
actually embody knowledge in external
forms that we then can pass on across
time across space and across multiple
generations we are the only species that
does that and we do it through
preservation so I thank you very much
as you can tell I think this is the
beginning of a very exciting time for
preservation and I know that I have
given a lot of information not nearly as
much as I would have liked to of course
but I would commend to you the two
reports of the task force and I would
simply I would say just Google
sustainable economics digital planet
that's a lot easier than trying to find
this the URL and it's it's the reports
were actually on the super San Diego
super supercomputer site and i also want
to recommend to you the Library of
Congress that has just published its its
10-year review of its end it program and
it's now online digital preservation gov
the ww preservation gov and there's a
full discussion about the many different
models of shared stewardship there that
I commend to you they're very frank
discussions of the various efforts that
were tried some failed but in the end
succeeded